[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 108 the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mock mando and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work how are you doing
today Melanie Happy New Year mark it's
the beginning of the year trying to get
back into the groove of things trying to
did you have a good holiday I did how
was yours it was good it was good it was
low-key which is nice nice so this week
we've got some friends of yours yeah
they're my friends your hands we hang
out all the time I figure out the pool
yeah yeah so yes this week we are going
to be talking to Malika Cantor and Peter
Norvig and they're going to tell us all
about launchpad studio which is
basically a program that supports
startups especially machine learning
startups before we get into the
interview we're gonna of course start
off with the cool things of the week and
at the end with the question of the week
and the question of the week is going to
be about how if you're a startup how
would you get credits to work on GCP
before we get into the cool thing of the
week what we do want to do is briefly
mention about vulnerabilities that have
come out last week around on modern
computers and specifically these
vulnerabilities are related to modern
processors and they impact things like
your personal computer your mobile
devices and the cloud now there's a lot
of content out there there's many
different links and will definitely
provide some of these on our web site
and we have some great information that
our security group has done on a blog
that we will provide around GCP and how
they're working to support that but the
main things to understand is that
meltdown inspector are two
vulnerabilities that you want to be
aware of you want to make sure you're
updating your operating system you want
to make sure that you are updating all
the things whenever you have the
opportunity to on your phones and your
laptops on whatever cloud services
you're working with and Mark I think you
wanted to touch on this briefly as well
yeah we're gonna link to all the blog
posts we are not security experts I
think Melanie knows probably more about
this than I do she can talk about
freitas but most importantly yeah
definitely upgrade all the things one of
the things that I'm just gonna literally
read off here for like Google cloud
right so if you're writing compute
engine kubernetes engine data flow data
proc they're awesome two extra customer
actions that are needed again links are
in the in the show notes but definitely
go through those make sure you get those
implemented as soon as you possibly can
so check out the links make sure you're
up to speed on that and let's talk about
cool things of the week yeah absolutely
so every time we seem to come on the
podcast we talked about GPUs getting
cheaper so why don't we talk about GPUs
getting cheaper so we're introducing
preemptable GPUs which is kind of neat
so if you ever used preemptable of GCE
instances so instances that may die and
put about 24 hours but you get a very
large deduction in price when you use
them you're now able to use GPU
instances on those now beta unavailable
for GPUs on preemptable instances we'll
have a link in the show notes as well to
the blog post which links to the
documentation and how you can do them
but basically if you wanted to batch
type processing for GPUs and you want it
to be a lot cheaper to do it especially
if you're using printable instances
already this is a really nice thing for
you yes cheaper is always better all
right and the other cool thing of the
week is that we have a couple of awesome
lists that we wanted to share with
everybody we've got some links we'll put
it into the website as always but
specifically if you've played around
with github but you've seen the awesome
and awesome list of Awesomeness there
are some awesome lists for tensorflow
they're awesome list for kubernetes
there's awesome lists for GCP Google
cloud platform itself and the awesome
lists are really you know using
contributors contributing what they
think are some really great training
resources as well as real world
application samples libraries analytics
they put out there what they think are
good tools and resources to have access
to and consolidate that down into a list
and I think mark you said you found in
here something that you guys had built
yeah I didn't I didn't realize that I
was just looking at this now there was a
gr PC sample that myself Sandeep Dinesh
and a couple other developer advocates
also did some work on where we took the
old game Simon with the multi colors and
made it playable over the Internet we're
using to your PC in communities and
that's on the list which cool and
finally is a really nice cool thing of
the week that is coming from the
community which is really cool I'm gonna
butcher your name I'm really sorry I'm
gonna will Fuchs maybe a data scientist
at defeated group wrote a medium post
called how we implemented a fully
serviced recommender system using GCP is
a really cool article in they use a pen
big query could cut storage data product
data store data flow to build a
recommendation engine but they also talk
through the recommendation algorithm
which I love is called dim sum I don't
know why thanks les that's fantastic
basically to build a collaborative
filtering recommendation engine which is
yeah it's really good read you should
totally check it out thanks all right
well now that we know what our cool
things are the week are we're gonna go
ahead and jump into the main content so
we are excited that we have with us
malika cantor who is the global lead of
launchpad studio and peter norvig who is
the research director of machine
learning at Google so before we get
started to talking about launchpad
studio we want to talk about a little
bit about your background so please that
reduce yourself a little more yes so my
name is Malika Kanter as you mentioned
I'm the global lead at launchpad studio
launchpad sits under developer relations
at Google we are basically the
accelerator engine of Google so we run
different accelerator initiatives
focused on supporting various startup
ecosystems across the world and studio
is focused on supporting specifically
applied AI and machine learning
companies globally Thanks and Peter we
don't really know who you are so you
mind telling us a little about yourself
hi I'm Peter Norvig I'm a director of
research here at Google I've been at
Google since 2001 company was a little
bit smaller than and been focusing on
machine learning for a long time working
on various tools and applications and
about a year ago started getting
involved with launchpad to help others
learn how to use those tools and you did
write the canonical book on AI that most
people tend to look back to was Stuart
Russell that's right
so you know I'm in the comm domain now
but I've had all the top levels so I was
in Eadie you was professor for a while I
was in Gov in computer science at NASA
and along the way I wrote a textbook and
kind of got involved right about the
front a little bit of background there
I know Mullica we were talking about it
too that you've had some great
experiences around the VC space as well
as especially in China and we want to
get into that a little further later but
first let's talk a little bit about
launchpad studio so you're explaining an
overview of it but what led to this
project what inspired you guys to to get
going with it sure so I mean as you
mentioned I was working in venture
capital investing in applied AI machine
learning and robotics companies for a
little while and one of the things I
realized was that a lot of the startups
didn't really have the tools that they
needed to be successful and so one of my
thoughts was well where can I go and
what can I do to actually make a
difference and this was about six months
ago I started like Peter getting
involved with a launchpad team and saw a
great opportunity to build a program
that would actually allow us to gather
more insights on what startups working
on applied machine learning in different
industries actually needed and for us to
then go back to Google and other
potential large tech companies and
inform them on what were the tools that
these types needed to actually implement
things at scale and grow and and be
successful so that was sort of why I got
involved and very early on you know we
started talking with Peter about his
interest in you know again gathering
these insights almost like developing a
lab where we were working with great
companies you know trying different
things with them bringing them amazing
mentors and then figuring out if there
were any sort of learnings across these
different companies and industries that
would then indicate that there was you
know that an opportunity to build a tool
on the Google side and so this could be
an API this could be a new type of
service that would then have impact
across the startup ecosystem and
everywhere in the world and across
industries and the program itself it's a
six-month incubator program to bring in
startups is that right effectively yes
so it's a six month program the way so
once we decided that we basically wanted
to develop all of these insights we
started thinking sort of from first
principles how it would make sense to
set it up
and we decided together to focus on one
specific industry vertical at a time to
allow us to really go deep and
understand what was going on there and
and really gathered really solid insight
so right now we're focused on the
applications of AI machine learning in
healthcare and biotech
so we basically onboard companies on a
rolling basis that are focused on this
vertical we already have four companies
that we've been working with for a
couple of months and checking in with
them every couple of weeks they come in
and work with us every few months and
we'll be onboarding new companies
actually just in two weeks we have a big
next event and so they come in they meet
with some a lot of different product
teams at Google but also mentors outside
and then in this whole process we're
basically gathering information about
some of their challenges so for instance
you know I've been using tensorflow but
I just can't figure out how to you know
scale up this part of my infrastructure
or you know I have this data set but you
know especially in the healthcare space
you know the disease I'm looking at only
allows for me to have quite a limited
data set how can i amplify and augment
that data set to actually use some of
the models that are best used in the
machine learning space a lot of these
types of questions were already starting
to see and I'd love to talk more about
some of the other sort of overarching
challenges that were already starting to
identify so you're actually talking
about that at those you said in the
beginning you said there are these tools
that are missing as those the tools that
are missing for those sort of problems
that people are trying to solve is that
is that kind of the gist yeah and I
might also let Peter jump in here I
think where all of this is very much a
hypothesis you know we sort of came at
this and and maybe a good analogy is you
know we were thinking all right you know
Lean Startup methodologies like we've
been accustomed to hearing this term and
we were thinking about it with machine
learning and this is something I started
seeing already and in my VC days is does
it really work like can you fail fast
can you pivot as a company that's
leveraging machine learning and our
general sort of you know understanding
was well no actually we don't really
think that it's possible and it's
because the tools are lacking like there
are some tools like you know tensorflow
is incredible tool GCP with we have a
lot
of other ones out there and you know
other people are building great tools
too but it's still extremely difficult
as a company leveraging these new
technologies to do what we think
startups should be able to do and so
through studio our hope is to really try
to understand what are the limitations
of the tools that are already on the
market which are quite limited to be
honest and then inform what are tools
that we should be building to hopefully
make it easier and easier for startups
to pivot and to fail fast in the machine
learning space so I think it's a
combination of the tools and best
practices and the knowledge and
experience so I came to this you know
I've been working internally with teams
who they're you know a large percentage
of the team of PhDs in machine learning
right and so they had some background
and intuition about what to build but it
was still really hard and now we want to
say well not everybody has that luxury
of being able to have a bunch of experts
of machine learning on your team maybe
you're you're in your domain whether
it's healthcare or energy or
transportation or whatever your your
your company is doing and you mostly
have experts in that and they don't have
the background that we had access to but
you have an idea that you have some data
you want to do something useful with
that data and you want to produce a
product how can we do that and some of
it is having the right tool but some of
it is just knowing what the whole
process is of how you go about starting
from the raw data or even how do you go
about collecting data if you don't have
any yet and building the whole pipeline
and evolving that and keeping going and
we just don't have experience with that
we have we've done a lot of one by ones
but you know if you look at history of
software engineering we've been figuring
out how to build software for 50 years
and we've only been trying to figure out
how to build machine learning system for
a small number of years so so
understanding how all that works is the
key challenge now and you've had the
resources finally to be able to
experiment with building up this machine
learning but barriers I know or
definitely yeah so you see you know
there has been this big explosion in the
last couple of years and and I think
that's a couple of things coming
together a lot of it as you say has to
do with the resources that now more and
more data is online that is you know the
internet is everywhere and data is being
captured in digital form so that's
available far greater computing power
that wasn't available in the past be
able to do things that you couldn't try
before and just I think one success
builds on another that if somebody
proves they can do something and then
somebody else says uh well that work for
them I think I can do it now too one of
the four companies that you're working
with currently what are some of the
tools that they are using and then also
some of the tooling that you both think
could definitely I mean we're talking on
it but anything specific that's standing
out that you think could be useful yeah
so in the companies right now again
we're like in the early days of the
program a lot of it is you know
mentorship you know giving insights in
in terms of how they could be leveraging
for instance GCP better some of the
api's that we've already built you know
they're working with teams like the
cloud machine learning engine team you
know the cloudy eye team but then also
the Android things team which is trying
to sort of push a lot of learning onto
the device now you know we're basically
working with a lot of different product
teams are coming in and mentoring
startups on what are some of the
services that we have already that some
of these companies could be leveraging
as part of their stack so that they
don't build that themselves because
there's there's no point there you know
what's interesting to the software
engineering point that that Peter was
talking about is you know a lot of the
the issues that we're seeing the start
are having is actually around
architecture and around you know with
software development you're thinking
about building an end product but with
machine learning you're thinking about
how to build a scalable data pipeline
and how to retrain a model and it's you
know the end product is almost like a
byproduct it's it's not necessarily what
you're moving towards and so we're
starting to try to figure out you know
are there things that we could be
building and we definitely are on the
way to this already with initiatives
like Auto ml in terms of you know
automating certain parts of you know
this this process of building you know
your software engineering and
development to help these startups do
this more quickly and better you know
the concept of potentially automating
DevOps also like I think there's a lot
of opportunities here but I think that
that is one thing that we've seen that's
been really interesting sort of aside
from other problems like I mentioned
around you know data UI UX there's also
you know it's a Peter's point there
there aren't tools for understanding how
regulation is going to affect your
product and so there it becomes more
about best practices and sharing best
practices across these different
companies that are working in one
industry you know our hope is maybe that
we can even build a curriculum to try to
help inform you know okay well be aware
of regulation be aware of how to go
about building you know how to do
software development how to think about
your data pipeline how to think about UI
and UX and so again to Peter's point it
goes beyond just the idea of tools it's
more about sort of sharing best
practices and learning from one another
so it's actually sounds really
interesting I'm quite curious you're
talking Peter about sort of the scarcity
of resources in terms of people people
with the knowledge are you finding that
one of the big challenges is that people
who may come in without that machine
learning Rai knowledge have anymore I'm
gonna say quote unquote traditional
software development backgrounds so the
pipeline and that the way that they
build things for machine learning in a
eyes is I don't know how different but
different enough that it's causing a
disconnect or that's like a big hurdle
you finding that a challenge yeah I
think that's right
so so one of it is really changing the
mindset for what you're trying to do
right
traditional software engineering you're
kind of thinking like a mathematician or
a logician and you're you know you say
well in the end point I could sort of
prove my program correct and you know in
reality you only do that in the
classroom you don't do it for any
realistic program but you're sort of
aiming in that direction I mean we have
tools like test frameworks where you're
making assertions and you're the
assertions are of the form the result of
this should be equal to that or this
should be true so it's very binary
true/false either you got it or you
don't
but with machine learning it's not like
that it's not mathematical it's more
like a Pyrrhic allure scientific
endeavor I was like doing biology where
you do an experiment on the world you
observe the results of the experiment
it's not that it's true or false it's
just you know most of the time is going
to be this and some of the time it's
going to be something else
and so making that change from thinking
from logic true/false to a kind of
probabilistic messy world that's hard
for a lot of people to give up on on
what they thought was the solid bedrock
and now embrace this uncertainty kind of
via what do you mean this is only going
to happen sometimes yeah so one of the
things I wanted to know is what do you
think is making your or what kind of
companies do you accept into the program
what makes them successful in this type
of program yes so our selection criteria
is quite simple so first it's are you
applying machine learning or ai to the
industry that we've said we're focused
on at the present time which is
healthcare and biotech right now and
we're going to be announcing other
industry tracks in the course of 2018
the next one is are you trying to solve
a specific challenge related to machine
learning in the next six months and the
reason why that is part of our selection
criteria is we don't want to basically
take startups in the wrong direction
like there are companies that are going
to be implementing AI machine learning
at some point there are some companies
that never will and we just want to make
sure that the companies that we do work
with because
we put a tremendous amount of resources
and time on our end but we also expect a
lot from the companies in terms of being
there in the program you know
implementing a lot of the the feedback
that we give them we want it to be core
to what their roadmap is in the next six
months one thing that I should clarify
is our main Engagement mechanism with
the startup so we don't actually invest
in the companies it's a slightly
untraditional accelerator program in
that we actually get them to draw up a
project proposal of what they want to
accomplish with Google in the space of
six months and we select them based on
their project proposal so they actually
have to give us metrics you know
deliverables goals for what they want to
achieve and then we give them a lot of
feedback in the selection process and
then based on that project we actually
admit them into the program what kind of
metrics it really would depend so you
know if you're a computer vision company
looking at cell dynamics and your
project is focused on improving
precision accuracy of detection of a
certain kind of disease looking at those
cells then it would be improving your
precision accuracy from 83% to 96% and
that would be the metric that we're
basically working on together but if
it's a company working the natural
language space then you know it might be
slightly different it might be more
about you know what are how many errors
can we detect in speech it could be so
it really it depends from one company to
another but yeah that's I'd say is is
the main selection criteria for sure for
us we you know it's it's less about
selling google products or you know it
we don't really have a very clear sort
of direct you know gaining back to
Google but Peter and I definitely when
we're looking at these companies are
thinking about what can we learn and
sometimes it's even more just from a
personal intellectual perspective of wow
this company is doing something that we
never thought would be possible and we
think there's something really
interesting to learn here but definitely
were as I mentioned earlier you know
trying to figure out what Google could
be doing and building to make this whole
ecosystem successful so the more company
gives us insight
into that the the better it's going to
be because we're trying to do things at
scale here beyond just making these for
companies and and other companies in the
program successful too so I'm actually
curious almost at a higher level to you
you you obviously verticalized it in the
ml space but now I'm also curious like
why specifically focusing on ml like the
set up space is huge we do a lot of
stuff across Google cloud why the
emphasis is specifically on M oh yeah
and you know I'll definitely let Peter
jump in here too from a launchpad
perspective so there's actually an
another phenomenal program that's being
run out of launchpad called Launchpad
accelerator that's been running for a
few years now been extremely successful
and they what they focus on is
supporting growth stage startups and
emerging markets and the whole vision of
launchpad and so we're affiliated with
ecosystem which you know our whole
vision and mission is to support startup
ecosystems everywhere in the world is to
identify startup ecosystems that we
think are particularly under supported
and so with accelerator it was you know
sort of thinking about next billion
users what could we be doing with
startups globally that would actually
give us insights and really make an
impact and then with studio again the
thought process was similar is you know
we have this as Peter was saying this
revolution going on this boom of like
more and more startups that are starting
to you know for better or for worse use
AI machine learning in certain cases not
in a very real way but you know there
was we identified a need and an also an
opportunity for Google to really make a
difference here you know to as Peter
said use some of our expertise of
building some of these products
internally and actually see if we can
teach anything and learn anything from
these companies are going really deep
looking at specific use cases and trying
to scale and productize some of these
things we've been working on for a few
years yeah
you know I think at Google we have the
luxury of in some ways being able to see
into the future that were at such a
scale that we run into some of the
problems and opportunities before other
people who had a smaller scale so we've
been doing this for a while and we've
seen these opportunities
and now we see a way to share that to to
help other companies overcome what we've
done in the past that they're just
starting to face now you were saying
before that there's mentorship that's
provided it's a six months program is it
similar to some of the other incubators
out there or is it different is there
certain things that make it similar or
different yes so I think as I mentioned
earlier the main difference is that we
don't actually invest we don't have a
financial relationship with the startups
that we work with there's various
reasons why that is the case you know
one of them being that actually it would
be very complicated for Google to have a
financial relationship with some of the
startups that we're bringing in from
different places in the world you know
you mentioned China earlier it's you
know we're very excited to be able to
work with companies without having some
of that red tape but it's also because
we want to make it very clear that this
is not a strategic endeavor for Google
and that this is you know almost a room
of peers of you know we have a lot to
learn from you we you know in many cases
we have mentors from our product teams
at Google who you know come to us can
tell us how much they've learned from
the stirrups that they've been working
with so that's one main difference the
other one is as I also mentioned we
admit companies on a rolling basis so we
don't really believe in the concept of
classes you know from from my background
working with startups and peter has to a
lot of people on our team were very
conscientious of the fact that you know
startups can't just drop everything you
know every like once in a while and and
and say okay we're gonna go in and join
this program and and you know basically
not focus on product development for
however long and and so the entire
program is designed in a way that's
trying to be very mindful of that and is
saying look you know you're closing your
round right now it might not make sense
for you to join this program but in a
month when we onboard our next batch
like we'd love for you to to come in so
that's the other one the third aspect
I'd say that it is a little bit
different is that we have no size fits
all one size fits all so it's um it's
completely tailored to each company we
admit companies that have 12 people and
have raised you know
$100,000 and companies that have about
thousand people and raised seventy
million dollars so that's kind of the
spread that we already have in our in
our current batch and so you can imagine
that a company that has 12 people and
companies as a thousand needs very
different kinds of support so we
actually really focus on you know
identifying what are the challenges of
each company and then build a totally
custom sort of mentorship program and
and solution for for each company which
is one of the reasons we only work with
very few companies at a time cool
you talked a lot of you talked about
sort of that feedback loop which sounds
fantastic and I think that sounds
wonderful I'm super curious to know
what's been the most sort of interesting
or surprising or like what feedback that
you've got or learning that you've had
from working with these companies Peter
do you have any so far that you'd like
to share I think it's just that
companies are really focused on solving
their problem and serving their
customers and so they see the technology
as a way towards that goal and the
technology itself exactly what it is
they don't care as long as long as you
can get there and so making it easier
for them to take advantage of that is
what we're trying to do so one of the
questions that I had you both were
saying this and I've heard this a lot
lately where people will interchange AI
and m/l how do you define it how do you
think about it in regards to especially
working with these startups so i guess i
i defined artificial intelligence as
doing something smart so figuring out
what you want to do and and doing it
well in a way that you didn't know how
to do before you know it so in some ways
i say that regular software is defining
program to do something that you know
how to do and AI is doing it for
something that you don't know how to do
and then machine learning just means
you're going to do that by learning from
examples rather than having the
programmer write down some rules or
something
and back in the 1980s we had the term AI
and we also have the term expert systems
and what that meant is you got an expert
in medicine or whatever it was and you
interviewed them and you figured out
what they knew and then you wrote down
rules that represented what they know
and so that was AI by applying expert
knowledge figuring it out by hand now we
tend not to do that we find that that's
brittle and slow and instead we do it by
collecting data and learning from the
data so machine learning it's achieving
AI through applying examples and expert
systems is achieving AI through
understanding knowledge and we also were
talking a little bit before I just
wanted to touch on it briefly before we
start to wrap up but you've got this
great experience working in China and
seeing kind of where their world is
going around the AI space so just as a
general thought of where you know AI is
leading us for for applied in real world
business applications what's your
perception of this ecosystem yeah I
think it was extremely exciting to see
Feifei
open the AI Research Institute Beijing
you know mid December last year a lot of
interest and excitement and a lot of
people working on it and we're seeing
new things coming out so for anyone
who's listening and is all like I've got
a business and we're doing ml and this
program sounds amazing how do they get
involved is there a way yes so just go
on our website there's an application it
only takes about ten minutes to fill out
we would love to get an application from
you you're actually allowed to apply
even if you're not working on healthcare
and biotech because we're looking at
applications to also influence the next
industry verticals that we'll be
announcing so again we're admitting
companies on a rolling basis
applications are open across industry
verticals but we will be working mostly
with companies in the healthcare and
biotech space in the next few months
also if you aren't a startup but would
like to refer company
please reach out to me and maybe we can
even share my information yes well we'll
definitely have them the show notes and
then the final thing is I'm also if you
are a subject-matter expert because I
think one of the big themes in in this
talk was basically effectively moving AI
machine learning out of the hands of
just AI experts and moving them
increasingly into the hands of subject
matter experts like healthcare and
biotech experts if you are a healthcare
and biotech expert or someone else in
another industry you're really
passionate about applying machine
learning and AI to your industry and
you'd like to become a mentor again
please reach out we work with academics
with you know industry veterans with X
CEOs we'd love to hear about your
experience and and you know your
expertise and nice that you give it such
a breadth in terms of being willing to
take in the mentors in terms of one of
the things I know we were talking about
before was that you guys have an event
coming up in a couple of weeks do you
want to tell us a little bit about that
sure so basically it's our second high
touch point so that's what we call the
event when the startups basically fly in
in certain cases we have two companies
that are based outside the US and two
companies in the u.s. right now and they
come and basically get a few days to a
week of back-to-back workshops and
meetings with a lot of Google teams and
external mentors like I mentioned so our
next high touch point is is coming up
we're going to be onboarding a few new
companies so you know if you're
interested in seeing what other types of
use cases and companies we're gonna be
supporting moving forward definitely
keep an eye on our website and on our
Google developers blog and yeah we're
really excited to to keep working these
companies and as we mentioned you
develop product methodologies from
machine learning and hopefully build
better tools for this whole ecosystem
thank you is there anything else that
you both wanted to touch on before we
close out this is really great to hear
about lunch pod studio and get some
insights in terms of how you're
supporting startups yeah I guess the
only thing is if peter has any other
thoughts because you know him and I
have had a lot of conversations about
this about you know his interest and
passion and again you know basically
empowering people who aren't yeah
experts across different industries like
I guess we really enjoy working with
companies and understanding what their
needs are and and what kind of tools
they want and and and how we're gonna
build that and we see that as real
challenges going forward you know so
what I think a good example of that it's
with speech recognition where we've made
great strides in the last few years
where now you can talk to your phone and
we're gonna get most of the words right
but now there's a next big step of you
got all the words right but how do you
respond to those words and and that
doesn't have to do just with language
that has to do with what is it that
you're trying to achieve and so we've
got to give the companies the capability
to say when I recognize these words
here's what I should do and do that in a
way that they can understand and build a
good product without having them having
to be experts in speech recognition and
machine learning and linguistics and
everything else but just integrated into
their product and you know again it's a
it's like in regular software
engineering we figured out how to build
menus and buttons and mouse clicks over
decades and now we have to do the same
thing with a with a speech interface and
it's all going to be no and and we don't
know how to do it yet so we're we're
looking to partner with companies and
help figure it out together and say
thing to Peter's points almost like come
and help us learn you know and and teach
us what you need and you know we're
really excited about working with a lot
of people so and actually just one
another question here what got you
inspired to do AI in general like what
got you into the field if I may ask
slight side note it just seemed like a
really exciting field and you know I was
in high school and I was lucky enough
that my high school had both a computer
class and a linguistics class so it was
rare that you
use had computers in the high schools in
those days and and I took those two
classes and said hey could we put these
two together and my teacher wisely said
yeah it's possible but not with what you
know so ever since I've been trying to
learn enough to be able to do it that's
great that she gave you that kind of
challenge and that you took the
challenge I'm glad you both were able to
join us thank you so much for sharing
the information around Launchpad studios
and anything else that you wanted to
mention or anything else you wanted to
plug before we wrap this up all right
well thank you very much to both of you
for taking the time today and having a
chat with us yeah thank you so much for
having us you know thanks thanks Monica
and Peter for that great interview we
appreciated the insights around
launchpad studio especially for those
startups out there that are machine
learning and want to have access to
different tooling and and resources if
you have any questions or want
additional insights on launchpad studio
we will as always put links on our
website and now let's talk about the
question of the week so mark if I am a
startup and I want credits to work on
TCP what is available to me yes so we
have a whole service program we've
talked about it previously on the
podcast but I think it's changed a
little since then which is kind of cool
so if you're a start-up and you're like
oh man I really want to use a Google
cloud for it you can go to
cloud.google.com such startups and it'll
show you the startup page which is here
and there are different tiers that are
available right now for different types
of startup packages so you can get
anywhere from three thousand dollars in
credit all the way up to hundred
thousand dollars in credit for one year
including as well like 24/7 support
office hours
spotlights like all sorts of different
things depending on what tier you're on
and all sort of needs you have there are
several actually we've had discard
eckhart labs which have been on the
podcast more than once is one of those
people who came through that program the
one thing to know though if you are
startup and you're looking and you want
to come through this program you need to
apply through your incubator accelerator
or VC firm there's a long list of all
those people that we work with our
platform partners I counted 142 nice
yeah it's a good number of people to be
working with so yeah if you're a small
business and you're looking for some
credits and it gives some insights in
terms of like the size what that means a
little bit of information around who
would qualify for the program
check out our link you'll see that
there's start package there's a spark
package and there's a surge package in
terms of the number of credits that you
can potentially get hold of and this can
be applied to all of GC and firebase yes
actually that's a really good point that
it goes to both TCP and firebase yes
which is also super cool if you aren't
part of one of those groups there's
incubators or accelerated programs there
is a mailing list you can sign up for
just to get updates to see if anything
changes or if new people come on board
that's there and obviously free trial is
also obviously available there we go
well that wraps us up for at least our
first interview out the gate for 2018
anything you want to actually share or
any places you're gonna be in the next
couple weeks I'm not traveling very much
queue ones for me is very quiet normally
I'm just sitting around trying to get
things done for Game Developers
Conference and March just trying to get
ramped up for that how about yourself
you off anywhere nothing to announce
right now but probably later yeah all
right cool well Melanie thank you for
joining me for the first episode of the
year of 2018 done yeah it's done and
thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
[Music]